oh I've missed this show so much Gotham
is back oh no man's land I have been
waiting for this so premiere episode of
Gotham season 5 final season god that
makes me sad so I'm gonna be doing these
episode by episode my plan is for them
to come out on Mondays which is a few
days further out from the day that the
thing airs then I would normally like
these to be but I just I don't got
weekends are tricky for me and having
the thing air like right before the
weekend makes it very difficult for me
to turn it around quickly consistently
so this is a plan right now but in any
case let's actually talk about this
thing
I'll get my one major complaint out of
the way I don't like that it open with a
flash-forward I dislike flash-forwards
just kind of in general I have a hard
time thinking of stories films TV shows
that opened with a flash-forward that I
felt that actually helped anything I
just don't like it it's usually because
they want to open on some really on
something really cool that if they
actually start at the beginning they
can't do and I almost never feel that
it's worth it
so that annoyed me that's it everything
else I'm I'm pretty on board for this I
always loved the idea of Gotham doing no
man's land because I like no man's land
the story anyway and Gotham as bonkers
as it is and as nuts as the versions as
some of these characters are yeah oh
yeah so we've got Gotham carved up into
territories and a real strangling of
resources so you've got penguin
controlling
that includes a factory where he's able
to build ammunition which means he's the
best armed you've got a Barbara who has
her her little carved out of territory
um that she's got with Tabitha
apparently Mr Freeze is warring with
Firefly we don't see it but that kind of
makes me smile just on principle
scarecrows doing his thing this version
of scarecrow doesn't do a heck of a lot
from me although now that I think of it
scarecrow is a character who I think
it's actually really hard to do much
compelling with that I think more often
than not good scarecrow stories tend to
revolve around like what his fear gas
does to other people he is a character
he's actually rarely been all that
compelling so I guess this version isn't
all that much worse than most others
you've got the GCPD
y'all holding down the fort trying to
protect as many people as they can but
they're running out of food and and then
you've got you've got the Riddler and
there was an interesting thing going on
so like he he wakes up like well
initially on a roof then later in a
dumpster he's like I don't know how I
got here I'm being he's controlling me
when I sleep and then he gets to a Mary
he's shouting it and eyebrows Oh
Riddler's the dominant right now and
Edie is the one peeking in at the
margins oh nice touch I like it
and Barbara I love I like I love
Barbara's new haircut a lot suits her
and I love the fact that Oswald as a
bulldog that he named Edward
oh that's just funny plus I really love
Bulldogs so like oh that was great
Selina that was actually surprisingly
emotional what was going on with her and
the damage and her not coping very well
with looking down the possibility of
never being able to walk again there was
some surprising emotional potency in
that I was pretty impressed and she she
played it strong that that was those
good stuff so getting I'm gonna start
getting into flat-out spoilers
okay here so here we go so I was really
caught off guard when Tabitha died like
I mean I know it's last season and I
know that the people who made it knew it
was last season like before they shot
anything so this was always a case where
any of these characters could die and
any other season aside from this one
tablet a day any character died a would
have gone it's Gotham they can come back
I don't think so now so I was surprised
to see a major character bite it in
episode 1 and in a pretty shocking turn
I think that I mean like her being kind
of a villainous I mean I say villain
almost everybody in this shows up and
it's part of why it's great but you know
you I didn't I didn't expect it if she
was gonna die certainly wouldn't
wouldn't have expected it here and but
it works it doesn't feel cheap it does
accomplish the thing of raising the
stakes because it establishes yeah these
characters can die and we and this time
we we mean it so it does that job but at
the same time it didn't feel like that
was all that it did it it worked well
and it pissed off Barbara which you know
any reason for Barbara just to go bat
crazy on everybody around her is a good
thing in my book we see Bruce inching
ever ever a bit more every bit closer to
to the
manning the the ending note of the
episode was a little weird it was a
little like oh but it I did really
really really really wish that I have
the next episode right off the bat so
this is ultimately a you know a
foundational episode it's setting up the
premise it's setting up the conflicts
it's setting up where everybody's kind
of positioned at so that you know in the
episodes to come everybody can just go
nuts which is what this show does so
very very very very well so I think I'll
wrap it up there
Gotham's back and I enjoyed almost
everything that we had going on here and
like there were characters that I
probably didn't even remember to mention
you know Harvey's as grouchy as ever
which is great and Jim Oh Jim bless his
heart he's still trying we'll see we'll
see how much of Gotham he can save so
Gotham season premiere for season 5 what
are your thoughts on it whatever they
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it whole bunch of stuff
to do down there as well because there's
buttons and links including went to the
patreon if you are the generous type it
does help I would appreciate it but in
any case for the time being I'll just
say that just remember folks you're the
council and I'm just the guy who runs
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]